[Music]
Akbar Ahmed has a sterling reputation as
a moderate Muslim and thoughtful
academic but there is a sinister
undercurrent to his new book journey
into Europe he calls for a new Andalusia
which to non-muslims who have forgotten
their own history conjures up the newly
minted historical myth of a paradise of
peace and tolerance under the benign
rule of Islam in reality however as I
show in my own new book the history of
jihad from Muhammad to Isis Jews and
Christians and Muslim Spain did not
enjoy anything remotely close to equal
rights with Muslims and were subjected
to the Sharia mandated discrimination
and harassment of dhimmitude punctuated
by occasional outright persecution
characterized by enslavement and
massacres since Islamic law has not
changed since then one wonders what
Akbar Achmed is really recommending to
credulous and unsuspecting Europeans and
now he has in a recent article called
upon Italy to quote remember its
pluralist past once again it is the
responsibility of non-muslims in the
West and no one else to be pluralist and
prove their tolerance notice that nobody
ever calls upon Saudi Arabia to remember
its pluralist fast when Jews Christians
and polytheists lived together in Arabia
no one ever calls upon Sharia States to
be more tolerant of non-muslims the onus
is always only on the West Akbar Achmed
characterizes the foes of mass Muslim
migration in Italy as if they were all
neo-nazis in the of fascists and
anti-semites with the strong implication
that no one would have any reason for
opposing that migration except for
racism and xenophobia he retails in
highly misleading fashion some
historical incidents but leaves very
important other ones out in the history
of jihad I offer some information about
Islam and Muslims in Italy that Akbar
Achmed doesn't mention the Muslim
conquest of Sicily began in 827 by 829
the jihadi invaders had been almost
completely driven off the island when
they received unexpected help an
invading Muslim army from Island
loose led by a general named osburgh
eben wakil although they ultimately took
Palermo the Muslims were not able to
secure the eastern part of Sicily they
were stymied both by the ferocity of the
native population and their own
inability to unite their various
factions the fighting went on for
decades in 878 the Muslims finally took
Syracuse and the booty was immense
according to the 18th century historian
Edward Gibbon the plate of the Cathedral
weighed 5,000 pounds of silver the
entire spoil was computed at 1 million
pieces of gold about 400,000 pounds
sterling along with the treasure the
Muslims enslaved over 17,000 Christians
the exact number is not known but
according to given it exceeded the
number of the 17,000 Christians who were
captured when the Muslims took tere Mena
and were sent to Africa to lead lives of
slavery the Warriors of jihad were
finally able to secure complete control
of Sicily in the year 902 the conquerors
treated their new domains with extreme
severity brutally suppressing the Greek
language and forcibly converting
thousands of young boys to Islam later
the Sicilians were able to drive the
invaders out but the devastation they
wrought was immense meanwhile in the
year 846 the jihadis attacked Rome which
was of course the grandest city in
Christendom aside from Constantinople
but were unable to get through its walls
the basilica's of st. Peter and st. Paul
outside the walls however as the
latter's name indicated were outside the
city's defenses the jihadis plundered
both taking as much silver and gold as
they could including a sumptuous silver
altar from Saint Peters but finding
Rome's walls too strong to breach they
continued down the Appian Way to nearby
Fondy which they plundered and Gaia
which they besieged although the jihadis
had left the immediate vicinity of Rome
the people in the great city were
thoroughly alarmed
despite the Muslims inability to break
through into the heart of the city the
Romans criticized Pope Sergius for not
doing enough to keep the city safe when
he died in 847 his successor Pope Leo
the 4th swiftly began shoring up Rome's
defenses building new walls and
repairing the existing ones
well as repairing the damage the Muslims
had done to st. Peter's and st. Paul's
that all this was necessary was taken
for granted by everyone the jihad forces
were still in Italy the threat was
urgent it had not yet become customary
for the Pope of Rome to proclaim that
Islam was peaceful and benign and that
the Koran was properly understood
opposed to every form of violence nor
did the Pope in those days decry the
building of walls as he does now if
anyone had been skeptical about the need
for Pope Leo's me walls they were no
longer so in 849 when Muhammad al-abbas
the emir of the a globbit dynasty that
ruled in north africa ostensibly under
the authority of the Abbasid caliph sent
a fleet to the mouth of the Tiber River
just 16 miles from Rome
Leo however had formed an alliance with
several Italian princes as well as with
the Byzantines and a significant
Christian force was there to meet the
forces that the Christians called the
Saracens in battle at Ostia a district
of Rome and aided by a storm that
destroyed much of the Muslim fleet the
Christians were victorious and the
conquest and Islamization of Rome was
prevented at least for the foreseeable
future elsewhere the Christians were not
so fortunate Gibbon recounted the
habitual savagery of the conquerors he
said it was the amusement of the
Saracens to profane as well as to
pillage the monasteries and churches at
the siege of Salerno a muscleman chief
spread his couch on the communion table
and on that altar sacrificed each night
the virginity of a Christian nun as he
wrestled with a reluctant maid as he
wrestled with a reluctant made a beam in
the roof was accidentally or dexterously
thrown down on his head and the death of
the lustful emir was imputed to the
wrath of christ which was at length
awakened to the defense of his faithful
spouse Congreve NCAA I'm Robert Spencer
Shulman fellow for the David Horowitz
Freedom Center and director of jihad
watch this video has been brought to you
by the Center for security policy
you